[Música]
la muerte de la joven kurda iraní maxa
mini bajo custodia de la policía de la
moral dio paso a una serie de protestas
a lo largo y ancho de la República
islámica de Irán protestas que han
tenido lugar desde el pasado mes de
septiembre del 2022 tuvieron un momento
de intensidad pero poco a poco han ido
disminuyendo Eso sí los reclamos
ciudadanos se mantienen Eso sí se
mantiene los repasaremos con nuestras
invitadas en unos minutos porque la
lista sigue siendo muy larga los
reclamos que están haciendo los iraníes
abarcan no solamente derechos civiles
sino también incluso hasta factores
diferentes en el aspecto económico Pero
entonces cuál ha sido la respuesta que
ha dado el gobierno iraní pues la mano
dura disparos a las manifestantes
detenciones y condenas tanto a prisión
como a la pena de muerte se estima que
unas 300 personas han perdido la vida
por manifestarse en las calles de las
diferentes ciudades iraníes esa cifra
También incluye a 41 menores de edad
cientos una cifra que es muy difícil de
especificar han resultado heridos y es
difícil saber la cifra de los heridos
Porque muchos temen incluso ir a los
hospitales por temor a las represalias
que pueda haber por parte de las
autoridades unas 16.000 personas otros
medios y otras ongs citan 20.000 otros
21.000 la mínima va por los 16.000 o
cercanas a las 16.000 personas han sido
detenidas en las diferentes
manifestaciones algunas han denunciado
y han hecho diferentes críticas y han
denunciado haber sido Víctimas de
torturas por parte de la policía allí en
Irán pero poco o nada se sabe de estos
casos porque como decimos muchos temen
denunciar que ha cambiado entonces en
Irán en cinco meses después del inicio
de las manifestaciones qué reclamos se
mantienen en qué ha cedido el gobierno Y
cómo está en la actualidad la mujer
dentro de iraní a raíz de esta explosión
social de este estallido social el
balance pues lo hacemos hoy en el debate
de France 24 para conversar sobre este
tema hemos invitado a Katy abugli ella
es analista de derechos humanos
activista iraní y se encuentra en la
ciudad de Girona en España y también
desde Barcelona también allí en la
capital catalana En España se conecta a
esta conversación
anaita nasir ellas politóloga y también
experta en temas iraníes ustedes
nuestros televidentes también hacen
parte de este debate dejen sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales en Twitter en
Facebook y en instagram nos encuentran
como arroba
franz24_s la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f24 a mí me encuentran en Twitter
como arroba santilogo no olviden también
que todos los contenidos del programa
están disponibles en Apple podcast en
Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
Muy bien pues comienzo entonces dándole
la bienvenida a Katy que fue la primera
invitada que presente Katy Gracias por
estar con nosotros en el programa un
gusto tenerla aquí y El Punto de partida
para este debate cinco meses después de
la muerte de la joven curveraní maximini
y el inicio de estas manifestaciones
ciudadanas que ha cambiado en la
República islámica
Buenos días Muchísimas gracias por esta
invitación y poder ser un poco la voz de
de los iraníes pues ha cambiado muchas
cosas en Irán desde que yo estoy
viviendo aquí tan lejos de mi país veo
una unidad de visión de movimiento de
sentimiento entre el pueblo iraní que
antes no había visto y todo esto hacía
un punto en común hacia
algo que la verdad era el anhelo de
muchos iraníes desde hace años pero que
no había un movimiento
conjunto de parte de todos
y ahora saludo a anaíta y también Bueno
le doy la bienvenida al programa y
también le hago la misma pregunta como
Punto de partida cinco meses después que
ha cambiado en Irán
Hola buenas tardes
seguramente lo que más ha cambiado que
ya nunca más nada volverá a ser igual
que antes de la muerte de massa por lo
tanto los iraníes están en un punto que
seguramente como habéis dicho no
las protestas no salen a la calle o no
se manifiestan como antes debido a la
represión masiva pero ya nada volverá a
ser igual y en algún momento todo
resurgirá y alguna cosa cambiará
continuó con usted para hacer la ronda a
la inversa hablemos de la mujer y Dani
en este momento fue un punto de quiebre
la muerte de Max a mini a manos de la
policía de la moral muchas de ellas
salieron a las calles empezaron a a
tomarse las calles de por ejemplo de
Teherán la capital sin usar el velo que
era algo tradicional y exigido por parte
de esta policía que se encarga de
mantener desde su punto de vista los
valores de la sociedad iraní Cómo están
las mujeres hoy en día en Irán después
de estos cinco meses que ha cambiado
para ellas
de facto no ha cambiado nada lo que sí
que ha cambiado es la actitud sobre la
que ellos luchan es decir el pañuelo
sigue siendo obligatorio a pesar de que
para nosotros desde occidente el velo es
un símbolo pero para ellas es además es
el símbolo de la represión del régimen
que se cruza con otras desigualdades
como puede ser la política la
socioeconómica la religiosa o incluso la
étnica las mujeres están en un momento
en el cual se atreven algunas en las
grandes ciudades y las mujeres más
formadas Aires en pañuelo por la ciudad
pero es porque son valientes y son
desafiantes y cada día luchan para no
desistir en su intento de conseguir ser
libres libres de elegir de vivir de ser
pero en verdad a nivel institucional y
legal no ha cambiado nada
Katy su perspectiva su opinión que ha
cambiado para las mujeres
yo creo que ha cambiado que han visto la
fuerza en ella en ellas y que también
están viendo luz están viendo Esperanza
están viendo que ya se están moviendo
hacia hacia una libertad por lo menos
que ha empezado
Y antes lo veían tan lejos de de ellas
no pero que ahora les eso les da mucha
esperanza y por y de allí toda esta
valentía como decía anaíta de de salir
cada día a la calle sin velo Aunque
saben a qué Se afrontan podrían
afrontarse Katy anaíta veíamos que bueno
la mujer fue una pieza fundamental en
estas manifestaciones en este punto de
quiebre para la sociedad iraní a eso va
mi siguiente Pregunta a ese punto de
quiebre que representó para los iraníes
poder Elevar la voz salir a las calles
manifestarse
críticas también hacer propuestas
sugerir todo esto lo que vimos a lo
largo de estos últimos meses en las
manifestaciones en las calles de las
ciudades iraníes pero desde el punto de
vista social esto que representó
entonces para un país muy conservador
con mucha presión a nivel internacional
donde se le pide darle a los ciudadanos
muchas libertades y se le exige el
gobierno darles más a los ciudadanos
pero donde el gobierno como lo decíamos
tiene mano dura si ha cambiado algo el
día a día para los iraníes o esto
simplemente fue un momento de
de manifestaciones ciudadanas de
estallido social que no han llegado a
ninguna conclusión cómo lo ve Katy
para los iraníes en general dice Sí
es que yo creo que los iraníes están
como muy orgullosos de que de que sea la
mujer quien se levanta porque la mujer
ha sido siempre considerada como Pues el
género el sexo débil y en este caso la
mujer es la madre también y también ha
sido porque han visto a sus hijos y a
sus jóvenes Cómo están sufriendo y ha
salido la fuerza como como madre que son
no y
es que es impresionante porque está
saliendo desde Irán la fuerza de la
mujer como no sé me atrevo a decir como
nunca entre comillas en el mundo no de
levantar una
como un movimiento
que abarca a todas realmente
muchos sectores de la sociedad Y
entonces
Está respaldando también a sus mujeres
hermanas madres hijas y esto al
principio parecía que no lo acaban de
creer no pero ahora cada vez más hay más
hombres que están respaldando a las
mujeres
Ya nadie nadita Cuál es su punto de
vista esto este proceso de reclamo
social liderado en buena parte por las
mujeres se mantiene o esto ya ha perdido
fuerza o la represión del gobierno
simplemente diezmó este impulso
ciudadano que análisis hace usted
las la represión es decir haber enviado
a la orca cuatro jóvenes que solo
salieron para pedir libertad
evidentemente desde la lógica del
régimen fueron efectivas otra cosa es
que desde la lógica de los Derechos
Humanos fueran crueles y masivas y
brutales pero para los iraníes
evidentemente eso ha sido algo que ha
impedido que la gente siga saliendo con
la misma intensidad pero no nos tenemos
que olvidar que esto es justamente una
lucha por los derechos básicos humanos y
universales y las mujeres son la pieza
fundamental del cambio porque Nunca
habrá una situación de Justicia social y
de un país libre laico y democrático si
no se cuenta con las mujeres y
actualmente las mujeres en el régimen
iraní en el sistema político que se ha
creado a raíz de la después de las
Revolución islámica 1979 es una es un
sistema en el cual las mujeres tiene
casi una subcategoría el 50% de la
población está infantilizada necesita
una constante tutela de una figura
masculina y esto las mujeres iranís
llevan 44 años soportándolo y han dicho
basta lo han dicho muchas veces pero
esta vez han subido mucho más el tono de
la voz y están secundadas como decía
Katy por hombres que no quieren que sus
madres sus hermanas sus parejas vivan en
un sistema así hay mucha esperanza pero
no es algo inmediato son como semillas
que algún día de verdad brotarán
anaíta continuó con usted así como como
uno lo ve uno pensaría que bueno la
mujer está digamos en una categoría
inferior en muchos dentro de esa escala
de valores en la sociedad iraní pero si
uno da un vistazo a las sociedades de
otros países musulmanes la mujer iraní
goza de muchísimos privilegios Comparado
con muchos otros países por ejemplo
yemen Afganistán bueno Incluso en Arabia
Saudita que es un país con una economía
inmensa pero donde la mujer está
completamente puesta de lado dentro de
la escala social cómo Entonces entender
eso Porque desde el punto de vista de
los musulmanes Pueden decir Bueno pero
las mujeres iraníes tienen privilegios
por encima de las otras y se compara
pero Tal parece que para la iraníes no
es suficiente
Irán es un país fascinante y lleno de
contradicciones y una de estas
contradicciones es el hecho que el 97%
de las mujeres están alfabetizadas y hoy
en día el 65% de los estudiantes
universitarios son mujeres Entonces
tenemos una gran formación de las
mujeres pero que no se corresponde con
el marco sobre todo legal y penal en y
del estatuto de la mujer y de su
situación legal en la familia entonces
las mujeres están constantemente en esta
diatriba entre tengo totalmente todas
las herramientas para poder ser por
ejemplo ingeniera pero después si me
tengo que ir a hacer un viaje de
negocios Necesito el permiso masculino
porque una mujer nenira no puede viajar
si no tiene el permiso de su marido o su
padre o su hermano o su abuelo entonces
Esta es una contradicción enorme en como
y es una esquizofrenia en la cual viven
todas las mujeres iraníes y por lo tanto
Hemos llegado a este punto de no retorno
seguramente las mujeres habrá muchas que
volverán a ponerse el pañuelo porque no
quieren represalias porque tienen miedo
o ya han superado el miedo hay muchas
mujeres que no tienen Nada que perder y
todo que ganar y están en ese momento es
un momento histórico es un punto de
inflexión El problema es que estamos
acostumbrados a la inmediatez y este
mediatek no la vamos a tener porque no
está saliendo los 84 millones de
habitantes de Irán están saliendo los
más jóvenes y sobre todo las mujeres
Claro está saliendo Una generación
distinta una generación que tal vez no
le tocó ver el la llegada de la
Revolución a este país ha crecido ya
durante el gobierno revolucionario
durante unos valores y un marco legal y
social muy rígido Y tal vez por eso es
que salen a las calles a exigir algunos
cambios que se ajuste también a la
realidad de estas nuevas generaciones es
lo que uno puede hacer de análisis Katy
usted que conoce También muy bien Por
supuesto la sociedad iraní como es el
papel de la mujer en la sociedad vemos
según nos explicaban a Ita que tienen un
pleno acceso a la educación hay mujeres
supremamente bien formadas a nivel
académico e intelectual pero a la hora
de poder llevar esto al terreno a
trabajar a competir por puestos con con
otros pares en este caso hombres pues no
es lo mismo
no solo a nivel de trabajo están Tienen
estas restricciones las mujeres de estas
años sino que también como
por ejemplo como
alguna profesión por ejemplo Yo soy
cantante canto Entonces yo sí estuviera
ahí no podría cantar libremente no podía
cantar sola sobre un escenario hay
profesiones que no pueden desarrollar
pero tampoco a veces no tiene ni
derechos básicos de ciudadano de una
ciudadana por ejemplo como decía no
pueden moverse libremente por el país
necesitan el permiso de sus de sus
hombres o en el caso de la separación
por ejemplo los niños automáticamente
son para el hombre y esto por ejemplo
limita que las mujeres Hay muchas que
aguantan unas cositas de invierno
simplemente por no perder el derecho de
estar con sus con sus hijos
sí es lamentable lamentable esta
situación quiero que pasemos ahora a
analizar un poco de lo que ha
significado para el gobierno islámico
estas estas manifestaciones el gobierno
en cierta forma ha cedido ha dejado en
libertad a excarcelado algunos de los
detenidos durante estas manifestaciones
algunas de estas de estas acciones se
dieron durante el aniversario número 44
de la de la Revolución islámica el
gobierno
anaita ha sabido leer este reclamo
social a lo largo de estos cinco meses
le ha costado entenderlo o simplemente
pone un poco de pañitos de agua tibia
ante la situación
es absolutamente una estrategia definida
por el régimen de dar una de cal y una
de arena o menos que un pañito caliente
porque al final la amnistía de estos
presos no había tantas condiciones que
impedían la amnistía justamente de las
personas más
problemáticas Por ejemplo si se les han
denunciaba por por ejemplo Por espiar o
por ser amigo de los enemigos del
régimen o incluso si había cuestiones de
muerte o si cuestionaban la seguridad
nacional es decir el régimen en cada año
en la festividad de la República
islámica realiza una amnistía pero
realmente Han detenido nosotros nos
fiamos de los informes de organizaciones
internacionales que están trabajando en
el terreno y están hablando de 20.000
personas detenidas sin garantías legales
por lo tanto el régimen ha hecho un poco
de es un experto en propaga nda es un
experto en parecer algo que no es y las
iranís de dentro de Irán lo sufren y lo
viven y son conscientes y ya no se creen
estas mentiras
Katy su opinión el gobierno ha mostrado
algo o por lo menos una intención de
ceder un poco ante los reclamos sociales
que análisis puede ser usted o por lo
menos ha atendido la mano para el
diálogo o sigue cerrado sigue
completamente bloqueado y decidido
imponer su su ley y decisión
si realmente el gobierno está teniendo
su propia estrategia en todo esto Bueno
yo hablo desde mi experiencia con las
personas que
conozco y en el ambiente que me muevo no
sé una experta en analizar realmente en
la parte política sino que yo como baja
ahí que es una religión es una fe que
está perseguida en Irán sé que ahora
mismo hay muchísimos bajáis inocentes
encarcelados Solamente porque creen en
otra ideología y en otras religiones en
otra fe Entonces por más que expliquen y
por más que se sepa que esto es una
creencia simplemente diferente Pero
siguen estando allí y cada vez más
alguna vez algún vas ahí pues está
poniendo los está poniendo los están
poniendo en libertad Pero en cambio son
arrestados pues cuatro más claro Katy y
entre la sociedad iraní entre la gente
que usted conoce Que supongo de haber
gente de diferentes generaciones
cómo está el sentimiento revolucionario
se mantiene ese ese apasionamiento que
movía mucho siraníes también ese esa
fuerza que unificó a los diferentes a
las diferentes etnias que componen a
Irán que las unió básicamente en este
sentimiento revolucionario eso ha
cambiado eso se mantiene pese a las
diferencias o críticas que pueda haber
hacia el gobierno se mantiene ese deseo
revolucionario o la sociedad está
cambiando
yo creo que se mantiene y ha cambiado de
forma es como un río con el agua que
luego bueno de alguna manera se cierra
el paso de agua pero este río encuentra
otras vías otros caminos Aunque pequeños
y diferentes pero el agua al final llega
llega al mar sea como sea y ahora mismo
está cambiando de forma de yo creo que
los iraníes están en un proceso que
están
entendiendo lo que puede ser llegar a
una democracia y además ahora igual no
están saliendo como antes a las calles
para pues dejar sus vidas pero
o sea dispuesta Sí pero que no como
antes pero que están pensando Qué tipo
de movimientos que dentro y fuera de
Irán De qué manera pueden unirse a las
fuerzas y De qué manera se pueden oír el
uno al otro incluso
diferentes etnias ya se sabía que se
querían pero ahora se están oyendo la
voz entre ellas ahora se están viendo
las caras y se están manifestando este
cariño que se sentía y esta Unión tiene
una fuerza indescriptible o sea Esto va
por las maneras así claro esa unión se
puede se puede percibir tal vez en las
mismas manifestaciones esta muerte de ma
examen impactó fuertemente en las
regiones donde la etnia mayoritaria son
los kurdos y pues porque precisamente
maxa meneera kurda Entonces
ha mostrado o solidaridad tanto de los
iraníes como de los kurdos a la hora de
manifestarse y de hacer un reclamo en
conjunto anaíta su análisis de este
sentimiento revolucionario
es que justamente el lema de mujer vida
libertad
galvanizado toda una serie de demandas
que estaban acumuladas y estaban
latentes en la sociedad iraní durante
todos estos años entonces el lema mujer
vida libertad viene de un lema kurdo
Jean jeans Entonces los kurdos tienen
una larga tradición de lucha de para su
autonomía para poder estudiar en su
idioma para tener más derechos no de no
de romper la frontera de Irán porque no
están hablando de Independencia están
hablando de mayor autonomía por ejemplo
pero sí que es verdad que hoy en día el
lema de mujer vida libertad recoge todas
las demandas de una sociedad que está
cansada agotada y se encuentra con que
el régimen solo tiene una respuesta que
es la represión masiva tiene todo el
aparato y toda la maquinaria tanto del
cuerpo de la guardia Revolucionaria como
sus
que sería la fuerza paramilitar sometida
que someta la población a la cual en
algún en cualquier momento que proteste
o tenga una critica hacia el gobierno o
hacia el régimen saben que la respuesta
es las detenciones las torturas y la
pena de muerte como les ha pasado a
estas cuatro jóvenes iranís que hoy se
cumplen los 40 días de dos de ellos así
como los cinco meses de la muerte de
massa y nos damos cuenta que para los
iranís la libertad no es algo inherente
solo para ellos porque ellos saben que
esto es una lucha global y ojalá ojalá
Irán llegar a conseguir ser un país
democrático y laico y libre Por qué
Porque sería un ejemplo para los demás
países de alrededor vecinos como en
Afganistán que como mencionabas están
aún peor que en Irán y sería viviríamos
en un mundo mucho mejor Con un Irán
libre y democrático claro daría
muchísima estabilidad a la región eso a
nivel político no sobra decirlo de
aclararlo vendría vendría bien para la
región aquí haciendo un poco el análisis
anaita continuó con usted para hablar
justamente de este aparato represor de
la pena de muerte que pues prácticamente
estaba abolida en buena parte del mundo
occidental o en la mayoría de los países
y allí en Irán sigue siendo usada a
plenitud para seguir marcando esta línea
divisoria entre el gobierno el gobierno
islámico y la sociedad y marcar esta
mano firme del gobierno el aparato
represor es es inmenso que más se sabe
de este sistema instaurado a lo largo de
estos 44 años de revolución uno de los
mayores inventos de la República
islámica a raíz de la Revolución fue
tenemos un ejército que es el que
defiende el país por la fuera de las
fronteras y luego se creó un ejército
que entre comillas defendía el interior
que solamente que son el cuerpo de la
guardia Revolucionaria que solamente se
dedica a defender la existencia de la
República islámica es decir su único
cometido es conseguir que se mantengan
los preceptos de la república islámica Y
que todo el sistema creado después de la
Revolución siga intacto por lo tanto el
cuerpo de la guardia Revolucionaria hoy
en día no le importa ni cuida de su
población al contrario no tiene ningún
problema en ponerse en su contra de
hecho hasta ahora todas las represiones
han sido llevadas a cabo por el cuerpo
de la guardia Revolucionaria y su brazo
paramilitar que son los basíes que son
los que después formaban las patrullas
de la moral que van las furgonetas
llamando la atención a las mujeres esta
este cuerpo de la guardia Revolucionaria
hoy en día se beneficia de la corrupción
galopante que existe en el sistema iraní
y tiene un brazo que opera en el
exterior por eso decíamos que Irán si
fuera democrático seguramente sería un
lugar muchísimo más seguro tanto para él
mismo como para los vecinos de alrededor
porque sabemos que la guardia
Revolucionaria y aquí en Europa y todo
movimiento que está solicitando que la
Unión Europea la incluya en la lista de
terroristas es porque ellos tienen
ayudan a esbolar en el Líbano a jamás en
Palestina a los uties en yemen a
muchísimos otros movimientos terroristas
dándoles financiación equipación armas
entreno por lo tanto estamos hablando de
un monstruo que antes era solamente una
parte del ejército y ahora mismo cuenta
con poder político económico es el mayor
constructor en Irán es el mayor
el que tiene mayor industria de
armamentística en Irán por lo tanto
estamos hablando de un poder dentro del
poder que entre ellos se apoyan y se
retroalimentan y por ese mucha gente que
está de acuerdo con el régimen no nos
equivoquemos los 84 millones de iraníes
no todos están en contra del régimen hay
un pequeño sector que se beneficia de
ello y no quiere perder ese poder es
enorme aparato finalmente no ha cambiado
pues estos cinco meses de
manifestaciones ciudadanas Katy y otra
cosa que tampoco ha cambiado a lo largo
de estos meses y veíamos con cuidado
desde occidente por lo menos desde el
continente americano y desde Europa es
la censura en los medios la censura a la
prensa internacional precisamente para
acceder a cifras para acceder a
información oficial había persecución a
los periodistas iraníes que estaban
reportando estas manifestaciones usted
misma lo mencionaba una mujer sola no
podía cantar o no puede cantar en un
escenario No puede haber una expresión
artística la censura como arma de
manipulación y de guerra eso cómo se
se vive en el día a día como lo vendo
siraníes en el día a día
esto es el punto que atrae la esperanza
sobre todo a los jóvenes que están
saliendo tanto y es que están viendo qué
es lo que está pasando en el mundo están
viendo que el mundo está respondiendo a
ellos
están viendo las las reacciones que
tienen en los medios de comunicación las
declaraciones que están dando a nivel
mundial y esto es la fuerza que le está
para seguir y porque simplemente quieren
tener una vida normal como dicen
yo creo que esto es sí que hay censura
claro desde Irán oye nada pero como
están abiertos al mundo Pues están
viendo lo que está ocurriendo realmente
Sí y están viendo justamente la
respuesta que ha habido a nivel
internacional que usted menciona hubo
mucha sintonía la comunidad
internacional se solidarizó mucho con la
mujer y Dani Y con estas manifestaciones
eso siente usted que ha bajado ese
interés internacional por la suerte de
las mujeres iraníes Después de cinco
meses
ha cambiado está cambiando pero yo creo
que es que todo todo tipo de evoluciones
tiene digamos es viva no la entonces va
cambiando de forma pero
yo yo veo que es muy positivo o sea que
por ejemplo ahora mismo todas estas
lemas que están poniendo día y noche
sobre sobre las paredes en las ciudades
están dando
mucha fuerza a nivel entre entre ellos
entre el pueblo iraní están uniéndolos
en la misma voz pero yo creo que yo
ahora por ejemplo veo que a nivel
europeo Incluso en Estados Unidos todo
en todo el mundo los iraníes Cómo se
están muriendo de un sitio a otro
de ahora mismo bueno donde estoy Pues en
autobús en en todos los medios van han
ido hacia otros países europeos han
hecho muchísimo esfuerzo para decir que
aquí estamos claro
vamos llegando ya al bloque final de el
programa nadita quiero cerrar el
análisis hablando finalmente de la
presión internacional también siente
usted que ha bajado esta intensidad de
la presión por parte de la comunidad
internacional en torno a estas
manifestaciones y poco a poco se le va
dando más vía libre o terreno al régimen
de los haya tola para que continúen con
su con sus doctrinas
esperemos que no y ojalá sigamos oyendo
la voz de los iranís de hecho nosotras
tanto Katy como yo formamos parte de una
pequeña representación de los iranís
iraníes que están fuera de su país y lo
que único que tenemos es un firme
compromiso de seguir dando voz a sus
demandas Porque tanto lo que va a pasar
en Irán la solución solo la tienen los
propios iraníes y desde fuera lo único
que podemos hacer es seguir dando voz a
sus demandas y presionar a la comunidad
internacional para que siga atenta y que
siga denunciando la impunidad con la
cual el régimen está reprimiendo lo a su
propia población porque ya lo comentaba
antes la represión es como la única
respuesta que tiene el régimen ante su
propia población que ya no está pidiendo
cambios en el régimen ahora ya está
pidiendo un cambio de régimen y este
régimen no tiene ni la voluntad
obviamente ni las mecanismos para querer
cambiar por lo tanto
los nombres de las mujeres que están
luchando ahora se están preparando para
nuevas formas de protesta esto es una
disidencia a largo plazo y es verdad que
hay que hablar y dar importancia a las
redes sociales porque realmente son un
espacio virtual de resistencia donde las
mujeres iranís encuentran sororidad
apoyo y nuevas estrategias y no se
sienten solas en su lucha
Katy llegamos a la parte final me queda
un minuto para las conclusiones muy
puntual por favor que sigue entonces
para Irán Katy que viene para este país
y rápidamente para que anaita también
prepare una conclusión concisa y puntual
por favor Katy
aquí estoy ha empezado y que estamos
siguiendo en esta vida y que cada cada
iraní está aportando
de forma diferente a este movimiento
Este cambio
la analiza su conclusión para el cierre
que el camino es muy largo que mucha
gente se ha quedado por el camino pero
solo hay una un camino que es libertad y
Justicia para todos y todas Muchísimas
gracias
Anita y Katy les agradezco mucho por
haber hecho este análisis para la
audiencia de France 24 debo aclarar que
aquí tenemos el análisis de dos personas
que están fuera de Irán lo pertenece
hubiera sido tener también a alguien del
lado oficial del lado del gobierno iraní
o alguien en terreno en Irán que nos
diera esta versión por lo menos oficial
para entender la perspectiva del
gobierno como debe ser para darle
equilibrio informativo a las cosas pero
la producción del debate de France 24
intentó por diferentes medios contactar
a alguien en Irán para tener este otro
lado de El Debate y pues no fue posible
y por eso hemos hecho un análisis visto
desde la óptica de afuera de las
fronteras iraníes que también sirve para
entender lo que está sucediendo allí a
nuestras dos invitadas les agradezco por
haber estado con nosotros es todo por
hoy En nombre del equipo técnico les
agradezco la sintonía la producción del
programa estuvo a cargo de Laura garzón
y la producción de invitados a cargo de
Tania Herrera siga con France 24
[Música]